Президент України у своєму виступі з нагоди Дня Конституції заявив:
"Орієнтація на Євросоюз та Північноатлантичний альянс
підтримуються абсолютною більшістю громадян,
про що переконливо свідчить динаміка української думки".
Виходячи з цього, Петро Порошенко має намір ініціювати зміни до Основного Закону
та закріпити у ньому дві цілі - вступ до НАТО та ЄС.
DW перевірила,
Так, за даними Київського міжнародного інституту соціології,
найбільше в ЄС та НАТО українці хотіли у 2014-му році,
коли Росія анексувала Крим і почалася війна на Донбасі.
Якби тоді відбувся референдум про вступ до ЄС, "за" проголосували б 54% українців.
До НАТО тоді бажали вступити 48% респондентів.
Утім, відтоді підтримка західних спільнот дещо погіршилась.
У 15-му році за вступ до ЄС
виступали ще більше половини українців - а саме 52%,
в 16-му та 17-му роках вже 49%.
Останнє опитування, проведене в червні 18-го року,
показало, що в ЄС нині хочуть 47% українців.
Динаміка настроїв щодо вступу в НАТО теж дещо негативна,
порівняно з 14-м роком.
Тоді 48% українців проголосували б "за".
У 15-му році таких було лише 40%, у 16-му - 39%.
У 17-му році підтримка альянсу на два відсотки підвищилась,
а цьогоріч залишилась без змін.
Схожі дані в Інституту Соціології Національної академії наук України.
Сплеск симпатій до ЄС був найбільшим у 14-15-му роках - 50 і 55%, відповідно.
А симпатії до НАТО дещо зростають, однак вони далекі від позначки у 50%.
Попри те, що з 14-го року настрої щодо вступу до ЄС та НАТО трохи погіршились,
вони усе ще значно кращі, ніж, наприклад, у 2005-му році.
Тоді, за даними КМІС, за ЄС виступали лише 33% українців, проти були 39%.
"За" НАТО тоді проголосували б лише 16%, проти - аж 57%.
Починаючи з 14-го року прихильників ЄС та НАТО стабільно більше, ніж їхніх противників.
Твердження президента України про те, що абсолютна більшість українців
прагнуть до ЄС та НАТО і про це переконливо свідчить динаміка громадської думки - хибне.
Опитування свідчать про те, що прихильників у ЄС та НАТО
стабільно більше, ніж противників.
Утім, проста більшість українців хотіла вступити до ЄС лише в 2014 та 2015 роках.
А до НАТО абсолютна більшість українців не хотіла ще ніколи,
але до цього Україна була дуже близько в 2014-му.